yeah welcome to this video but do you
start three minute session again and
some of the recording areas to start it
so let's go okay so i go plane idea
three FML like this line i don't know it
very well this might get tricky with
long castles but let's see what happens
what's ideas place c-45 quickly so c4
known if I if I can play d5 should be ok
so I'm don't know maybe black just play
c6 yeah awesome pin some normally move I
think I'll go just just short castles
and maybe Queen a 40 k took right I
don't mind to get the two bishops I see
me think this maybe even a theoretical
line are the check here ok we go 92 what
is he doing maybe Quincy for I know
and then e5 it's not easy to get out of
the spin Quincy for queen bee three I
queen bee three maybe queen bee three
forget swooped if I can take b7 with the
Queen so Quincy for queen bee three
should be okay otherwise I'm just a
pizza for two pawns yeah rook t5 got
Quinn b7 King on the default XD 41 wins
the Queen so you cannot take on d4
really young this is just an extra piece
just need to be cautious here so should
I be four maybe before b5 immediately
try to open up the a file and now maybe
be 50 opening this yeah it's got the
check but you don't mind that too much
okay Bishop c3 maybe winning the a poner
getting some favorable exchange she
takes on c3 other will just take for the
night i guess the night covering b5 and
allowing for King e2 it didn't do that
if I take on d5 now you cannot check
with the rook just a second at the end
of all this that's rookie one mate
cautious it'll be a stuff careful here I
could just take g7 though don't see em
why I shouldn't
just drop back just g3 kingi to ya think
so get home we can get the King out of
this ya need to drop back I he's got
night h4 I'm such an idiot I didn't see
it very lucky it still has a threat
though not a three-page phone what if
one material back this is all very very
bad flavor me okay at least he didn't he
didn't make anything out of his channels
there should be now clearly winning
again goodnight b-52 293 to be five
winning a more material yet those lucky
resigns alright so
he could have gone light edge form here
so this would be a very embarrassing
Clea that what song is kind of lucky
next game coming up all right a trump
offski so what should i do I usually
play on this kind of setup with these
six so quite solid but this opening you
cannot expect too much it's black just
the solid position all right let's take
on deform on eat XD form which is
normally played I played e6 but this is
some of course much more boring seat XD
form try to exchange this Bishop yum
okay so this one was hanging on a 6 will
go to be seven with the Queen and white
um what is open maybe slightly better
here still have fun somewhat awkward
night on a six and now this havena so
maybe threatened should I play be five
young maybe could be a weakness but
don't want to do to make any passive
move here defending d7 Saudi six here
might might play a 4 here
okay maybe t6 get rid of the I could
just play knight c6 a while I'm not
really awake here pull wow this is
really awful Matt loose b5 if not if
nothing even worse is happening okay
let's let's play this capture with the
look only seven when i'll ever be our
yeah i'm not not not much choice
otherwise be five might be lost well
very ugly position oh so Brooks e7 name
and I'd still it's the fairly solid
what's really not doing much but the
spawn structure is liability even even
deep into the endgame yeah the smart
term intend to play no reform want to
prevent that
yet maybe still is around equal but not
much fun p3 is somewhat strange why we
can the dark squares maybe this is an
idea yeah and now I to before shouldn't
I I win da porn now okay she enters here
with the Queen time money but it's um
it's just one or two checks at the
moment just go here also threatening the
night I could even take b3 here but
maybe just retreat just retreat all the
way back end cover all the pawns Nigeria
five this could be a problem but maybe I
can get yam let's let's try to get the
knight to f6 clock should be nice light
to f6 covering the h5 square like this
the ship to secure the king no checks
anymore and next I must try to push push
pawns
so maybe I can maybe i can even now get
active here let's love something like
this checking III on e4 I can relay
Quinn f4 yeah okay but this is an ident
game which should be just winning we
have just a couple of points up in the
night end game okay this channel isn't
the greatest move either but should
still be okay so i have so many extra
pawns check checkmate alright so I'm
looked a bit rocky but Queen a six-night
before this I did the trick ya b3 is a
bit weird i don't know why i should do
that just a normal moveout no might be
three or something should be our should
be okay I think maybe it's equal that
those ponds are not such a huge problem
I should be a be winning quickly at
least add this before I don't know it's
not really a threat but the tailings
annoying ok well let's break deform mix
it up yeah go play the exchange so we've
got such a huge score with this opening
really should play it more often
some black now can play all kinds of
moves Bishop f5 Bishop g4 this one I
don't know it's a normal I'm idea but
somewhat strange them with this point at
this point yeah but what could be the
difference ninety-two don't know night
and knight on f3 and Bishop on GSM would
be a normal position all right don't
down and spend too much time on this
already so this is some very similar to
gruene felt okay want to click we need
for maybe queen a phone book c1
something like this should be ok but of
course black black is fairly okay here
shouldn't have any problems okay so how
could I improve this position here yeah
I also see phone and he cannot really
move the queenside but i'm not sure if i
have okayed he opts for complete
exchange is fairly okay for like here
the bishop c7 harassing the noid
some 95 an idea or just wait wait wait
what about this kind of stuff with the
idea of bishop be eight you should be a
to come okay this should be eight how
does he protect a seven now I can play a
six this was stupid just a six wow this
was really awful time money he really
didn't know there wasn't much happening
and now it's good just just a potential
ass porn I hope I'm quick enough with my
king yeah hopefully I'm it's still okay
the King shot damn should be enough to
stop the porn night g5 maybe was an idea
need to keep on that idea in mind okay
immediately prevented this how should I
proceed d5 maybe d 594 something like
this ok let's try
94 attacking taking the pawn maybe he's
got an IP to now I should have taken
only six and then play 94 this would
have been really okay this can get
really tricky now I would have taken
it's just just fine for me okay want to
so this should be okay now right what is
he doing King move i can play 94 again
not be too i can just go to see two and
he's got beat the night and the porn
hanging alright so just take and it's an
extra pawn suddenly ya don't mind this
phone is not so important i have a very
nice structure black resides yeah plus
the time also yeah this was a rather
draws i think this is the sole endgame
but then here should just take on e6 and
ta Scott not be too and this this was
the one move I i was i was some a bit
afraid of yeah I didn't do it ok let's
request the next game while I'm waiting
so this kind of schedule wasn't sure
chop-chop this may be chopped gads it's
about equal this kind of this kind of
endgame is equal both sides some or
maybe can I get before King c4 then
somehow try to win the pawn I don't see
how I should attack the porn now maybe
it's a draw maybe it's a drone horizon
story on here's a new game so let's play
okay I'll play a bit risky yeah going
for a Dutch set up this is actually I'm
really risky you know he knows his stuff
53 sm the critical move DD 3n deform
it's not playing e-form not sure ah ok
this is the idea it just wants to to win
the F porn I didn't really pay attention
to this because it looks so weird but
maybe you can't be can't do that yeah ok
let's say ninety form trying to cut off
the Queen and now I'm threatening Knight
f6 I'm almost winning the Queen this
kind of pond perhaps some are rarely
playable really o Knight f6
don't I win the Queen how does he save
it when you five hour play Bishop c7
hundreds and it's just gone I watched it
was tough anyway I think but this is
just a queen yeah it was quite a good
trade off this f5 part for the Queen
okay so let's grab here fight for Fitz
due to this connection I have the good
old poor man's way of resigning yeah
just the Queen for peace all right next
game yeah usually this kind of
stonewalled setup is a bit tricky here
because white can play for a cookie for
93 and you form this is some rather
dangerous for black so this is nothing
now I would really recommend I'm just
trying to play something else game
started can a deform huh GM here from
what is this are there by John it
doesn't have a name in there but other
but John's got a bunch of good players
yeah the Greenfeld okay I try some real
line that i recently saw it's a pretty
good way to get a non theoretical
position but still yeah I have something
something interesting on the board aha
very quick e 6 cut what about 9 p-5
might be five a problem nightly fire
Queen B 6
okay let's try this so it's maybe bit
risky I'm thinking about Queen B 6 and
then taking on on e6 with the intention
of playing 96 or queen g6 something like
this yeah now queen d 6 hmm yeah guess
this all a bit naive what I play here
okay let's try it anyway 9 a-6 is the
the problem which I ok so he's some
sucking the beep on of course though he
will get some some very good
compensation okay preventing rupee aid
because of the check and my intention is
to play Bishop c4 potato exchanging the
light squared Bishop okay so f3 is this
too much I don't have anything developed
the so yeah now I might pay dearly for
all this okay look before I thought okay
yeah he's got c43 this kind of this kind
of things
time morning I can actually play a b3
because of the check you should buy
three we should be three might be the
move that saves me Roxy three should be
two yeah now it's should have should
have covered this rename but the problem
is small more the time position is
rather okay don't have any problems so
just the time yeah no not the position
also yeah and the time I go I got myself
into troll here and then had this time
problems
ya can just take him white resides yeah
yeah well in this position well I'm just
incoming i'm just i'm just a pawn up for
nothing would be 3i not for nothing it's
got some compensation but it's i should
never lose really but i didn't have any
time on the clock he didn't make much of
his initiative here here look before for
instance which would better thing 95 is
not bad yeah but drop before is just
better yam close to consolidating he
also route see one I mean no big deal i
just spent too much time keeping this
position together okay oops sorry this
bottle of waters making some weird sons
alright i requested for new game but i
guess people are watching the olympics
so it's rather quiet on icc in general
this this line here is it's quite a good
choice if you want to avoid all kinds of
theoretical discussions and this is
still a playable position he sixes I
think rather only him not an expert but
very often like just castles 97 and
stuff like this and watches place you
should have to answer alright so mullets
let's vary a bit with the friendship
play the classical variation
yeah here black has got all kinds of
moves a six Bishop e7 okay let's play 86
hmm maybe this one I don't know really I
played the French years ago and sort of
forgot almost everything this should be
a too bad though okay maybe maybe wants
to play before can I played before
myself you cannot go all night a four
and i'm opening up quickly here
threatening be to deform what about
deform we're not just winning a pcl is
there some brilliant trick play resigns
nope there is no brilliant trick alright
so just a quick win for team moves
against them and I am does it happen
solve name is two min the gnome never
hidden tomb in like two minutes time
control two men okay so I've got a new
realist style out quickly here okay
opponent nervous waste of time from
Germany let's have a look I no name in
there i go for the exchange again let's
see what he comes up with so the
classical answer the symmetrical one
yeah this is the kind of line which is
so very solid for both sides with
actually wide can always try a bit on
the core inside I'm slightly quicker on
the on the C file for example with Roxy
one next never be three to cover the C 1
square it's really nothing much don't
need to learn to be too ambitious here
but it's um it's quite ok you can you
can play this ok don't want any doubled
pawns yeah now I potentially have a good
night against the somewhat silly bishop
the night would have a really nice
square on c5 so Knight d2 to be 32 c 5
would be an idea but down this is all
really slow I me I should play move like
this first you might play Queen B 5 and
possibly i also have rook c5 yeah maybe
Roxy 5 this is debatable ready if this
is a good move you have a five-year
exactly but I have three against two on
the queenside I can try to make
something out of this
yeah I need to play B form maybe this
one preparing before now huh it doesn't
mind the Queen exchange yeah well I
guess is right it's so not a big deal
Lex got a center and so on ok so light
to be three then I need to get my king
involved yeah black a sudden be okay no
no big deal I need to get the King into
play alright so maybe you will take yeah
not much that I can do 95 maybe now 95
if he takes ok one that I get get the
porn back young ok
yep I think he was correct and doing
this anyway ty morning rook do you one
yeah he's got this a 5 a DM maybe I'm in
trouble here as possible
if I need to move my king at some it's a
bit bit weird so g6 of f3 okay now i can
i can just drop back and it's a row grah
grah yeah i think it may be a draw
anyway gain okay started next one
another i am from Germany lots of German
players here I'm I think I'm one or two
victories away from getting to 2300 here
on the family pool so okay the quiet d3
line yeah just a rather typical kind of
position in this d3 stuff intention is
92 g8 had before was also possible now
he's got the a phone yeah this was my DM
trying to quickly play a five yeah but
this one who didn't camp I should have
paid more attention to this he can
simply drop back and now a five looks
really loose okay oh I was more afraid
of deform really
explain very quickly I don't know
shouldn't I be halfway okay here it's
not brilliant maybe but the perfect
world I can sacrifice on h three okay
maybe maybe i can go rook to g6 really
getting something going here doesn't
look too bad okay but sacrifice now he
will have Queen to f3 so this doesn't
help so much okay maybe get rid of this
Bishop it is an annoying piece anyway
okay you can play d5 I hit my playbook a
60mm okay six if i move the night you
play book aah not good not good at all
huh yeah we add still has something all
this looked really strange to me but wyd
still is better oh it's really
uncomfortable now how do I get out of
this looks very bad I know this is a
self pin but hmm maybe it's still okay
not very comfortable but maybe it's
still okay don't 195 k
and 95 wow this is really the past this
game I saw that but maybe I want to get
some activity going at least a bit I
don't know maybe this plan does
everything but don't have much time I to
put them yeah of course the pre move
thought it would took with you to take
with the other piece cash should really
resign but it's very slow yeah it just
takes on on f7 all right check check so
late ah why this was terrible what a
crap game I mean all this cannot
possibly great for what I cannot believe
it lose them all this time and so on but
I must I must have made something really
terrible here
maybe we just d 5 I wasn't I was
thinking about the five but I rook a six
looked looked somewhat annoying of the
spin but maybe I should do it anyway
this 98 was a bad idea i guess now ok so
one more game and then it's done 1 45
minutes around this I don't want this
video's to get any longer yeah just t5
silly and I don't know it really was
just checking the name proclaim don't
get a game game story are the same guy
alright so time for some revenge yeah
kind of Go Go Indian setup just am
developing normally at one point you
will play exactly this and then i'll try
to make something out of my space
advantage
jump like a some fairly solid here how
should I am make some progress not not
that easy so tough to breakdown
structure okay maybe maybe not f5 and
then f form I'll try that and then maybe
f4 next move opening up the position
it's got a nice looking night but it's
so not clear what this piece is really
doing
so should I play this f4 I should die
yeah let's let's open it up I had some
alternatives of course Quincy three this
this may be the stupid looking move
maybe good look at for Quincy three and
rooks and Bishop is hanging ok not much
I can do rookie to I need to play then I
need to be cautious though if you move
the Queen I might have f6 and this can
get get ugly quickly all right I don't
want to exchange Queen cm the deep on
this week this also get some
coordination to my position yeah just
piling up on the depot now so what what
to do to improve further is FCF 6 a move
time money not sure all right let's play
this so right well I'm not sure if this
is good he actually allows me to play
you should be 5 surprising Bishop should
have a good position on this square yeah
I wants to play a form but I try to get
something going here against the skin
rug age form the IDM age form
yeah his report now now I need to get
the King into play ya don't mind oh we
pawn this also very weak jaw f4 check I
hope it doesn't have some really silly
meeting stuff going be decidedly unfair
so mate yeah it is unfair how will you
add 10 seconds of the clock yeah of
course I should never lose this game
like it sir it's just just worse all the
way and now maybe okay and computer
actually things this is a draw yeah
maybe he's got some counter play going
but I don't know I should have won this
somehow but it was too slow yeah thanks
for watching some entertaining games out
and here talk to you soon